[MUSIC PLAYING]
VIC IGLESIAS: My
name is Vic Iglesias.
I'm a Cloud Solutions Architect.
And this is--
IAN LEWIS: I'm Ian and I'm a
Developer Advocate at Google,
based in Tokyo, Japan.
VIC IGLESIAS: So
today we're going
to walk you through how Google
Cloud Platform billing works
as well as show you some cool
things you can do once you have
the data at your fingertips.
Cool.
So let's get started.
So a lot of what
happens in the Cloud
is, you need to do something,
you start a new project,
you start hammering
away using new APIs,
creating new data sets, new
databases, new instances,
and you get something working.
So that's great.
So now you have
something that works
and you often kind
of build off of that.
At no point did you really
think, what kind of instances
am I using, what
kind of products
am I using, how are
they built. So someone
comes by, the engineering
team, and says,
hey, so what is the money
you're spending for development?
Like well, we don't know we
just kind of spin stuff up.
what are you doing
to run in prod?
Well, you know, the
bill of looks like this,
we think 80/20 to have to prod,
but we're not really sure.
So at some point, you have
to kind of wrangle this back.
So today we're going to go
through how billing works,
show you how you can
estimate for the future,
show you how you can look at
your past spending, how you can
slice and dice your
bill so you can separate
different pieces
of it, and then how
you can export your data,
which is when things get really
interesting, and then we'll
show you visualizing your bill
using Data Studio.
And that's where Ian is going
to blow your guys' minds.
So let's get started.
So what does billing look
like in Google Cloud platform?
First we'll start
with some terms.
We have projects.
And projects are
an isolation domain
that lets you place
resources inside them.
So every resource you
create in Google Cloud
is within the
context of a project.
Each project has a billing
account associated with it.
You can have many
projects associated
with a single billing account.
And the billing accounts are
associated with some way for us
to charge you.
So this is a diagram
of what it would
look like to have three projects
and two billing accounts.
At the top we show
the funding sources.
So you have a credit card that's
associated to a billing account
or a bank account that's
associated to your billing
account.
And those generate invoices.
You can also do online
billing, which will invoice you
at the end of the month.
Here you can see
that billing account
one has two projects
associated with it
and billing account to
only has one project.
So that's the high
level overview
of how billing is
architected in Google Cloud.
So what if you are really
judicious about your Cloud
usage and you
actually want to know
before you start using
something how to figure out
what it's going to cost you.
Well, we have our
Pricing Calculator.
So you can enter in all
of the different products
you intend to use and, this
is often a hard thing to do,
but you're just getting the
shape of what your bill is
going to look like and where you
can save some money if you do
or don't use certain products.
So you can go ahead and look
at that Pricing Calculator,
it's easy to find online.
What about going back and
looking at last month's bill?
So that's pretty easy.
In our Console we have
a billing overview.
Breaks down line items
of different products,
shows you how much usage you
had for those products, .
And how much you
were charged you
can also go back to past
transactions and past bills
in the console in
the transaction view.
And has a very similar
outline of what you guys have.
I get some credits every
month to use on Google Cloud
so you can see my bill
was negative, which is how
you want to keep it if you can.
And then.
At some point,
you're going to want
to put some guidelines
in place to make sure
that the right people know that
the usage is getting either out
of line or staying in line.
So we have what are
called budgets and alerts.
So you can set a budget and say,
this account, or this project,
should not go over this
amount of money in a month.
And then you can set up
percentages of that budget
that you want to be alerted on.
So for example
50%, 90%, and 100%.
You may not necessarily
take corrective action,
but you can at least know
that it's happening, right?
If you get your 50%
or your 90% alert
on the third day of the month
something's probably off.
So you can go check it out,
figure out what's going on,
and then act on it.
Now that you've
seen all your bills,
you can get a line item
of each product that
was used within a project.
What if you have
multiple environments
that you have running
within a project, right?
This is very common where you
have an environment that's dev.
You can use our labels, which
are key value pairs, in order
to label different
resources in your project.
For example, I have some
Cloud Storage buckets
and some compute instances and
I can label a subset of them
with the environment dev.
I can also go ahead and label
my production VMs and storage
with the [INAUDIBLE] production.
So now, when I look at my
bill, I can see these labels
and be able to partition my
spending into different groups.
And since these are
key value pairs,
you can do whatever you need
for your organization that
makes sense.
This is where you get
really powerful features out
of your Cloud Platform Billing.
When you start exporting
billing data and can use it,
do your data science, or
your machine learning,
or whatever you need to do in
order to get some insights out
of your bill.
So.
We allow you to export
your billing data
straight into BigQuery.
And we've all heard how
powerful BigQuery is.
So you can export directly
into another project
so you can choose a
project and a database
that you want to
export your bill to.
And you can also export
straight into GCS.
So just get a CSV dumped
and use your favorite tool
whatever that is.
Obviously, our favorite
tool is BigQuery.
We recommend it and
we'll show how powerful
that can be in Ian's demo.
So what is the demo
going to look like?
So we're going to have a billing
account that's associated,
that has two projects
in it and we're
going to be sending both of
those projects' billing data
to a third accounts
BigQuery database.
And from that BigQuery
database we're
going to send our
data to Data Studio
so that we can create some
nice dashboards, right?
We want to have
an executive view
of what our bill looks like.
Nobody wants to be looking
through a transaction
view at the executive level.
They want to have something
that they can kind of glance at
and say, we're kind of on track
or be able to dig into a bill
really easily.
So we're going to
set up this dashboard
and Ian is going to take it
away and show you how it works.
IAN LEWIS: Awesome.
Let's do that.
[INAUDIBLE] MyPC there.
We switch over to MyPC.
There it is.
VIC IGLESIAS: Yeah.
IAN LEWIS: There we go.
All right, so here's
my billing account or,
this is the Google
Cloud Console.
And so I have a
My Billing Account
for this particular
set of projects.
And so, while we're
here we can take a look
at some of the different
pages that Vic talked about.
So here we have the
Budgets and Alerts
field so you can kind of say,
create budgets and give it
a name, Overbudget.
Something like this.
And then, you can
specify an amount.
And you can specify
these in percentages
as well, also, if
I remember right.
Yes, down here you
can set percentage
of a budget or an amount.
And you can actually
set these to over 100
if you want to as well, in
case you're really over budget
and you want to get
alerts when how far
you're over budget as well.
Also, you have the
transactions page.
And right now,
this particular one
doesn't have any transactions.
We get a nice,
nice graphic here.
But this is what I really
wanted to talk about today,
which was the Export page.
So this is the most
powerful part of billing.
So here we have two options.
We have one, to
export to BigQuery.
And we can show, also, this
file export as well, where
we can actually export
JSON data every day
to Google Cloud Storage.
And here we can specify a
bucket and a report name
for our prefix.
And this will just get
prefixed to the file names.
And then we can export
that in DSV or JSON.
And that's great, but the
files are not as easy to parse.
It will put a new one
in there every day.
So we, want to do is
export to BigQuery.
And we can select a project
and the BigQuery data set.
And then, just click the
Enable BigQuery Export here.
So if we do that, it will just
start exporting to BigQuery.
and it's really
as simple as that.
inside that data set it'll
create a new table for you.
In that table it will
start putting the billing
transactions.
And it essentially does
this in, not real time,
but close to real time i.e.
maybe every day or
about every day.
So you can essentially
just query this table
and get the latest data
about your particular billing
account.
So let's look at what
that table looks like.
So over here in BigQuery
we have this table.
So it comes into our
dataset as a table that says
GCP Billing Export.
And then it's got some extra
characters after the end.
So if we click this
we can see our table.
And this is the schema that we
get when our table is actually
created.
So here we can see our
building ID, product,
the product is at the level of
something like Compute Engine,
or App Engine, or Pub/Sub.
And then inside each of those
products we have a resource.
So inside of Compute Engine
we have things like instances,
we have VM instances, we have
networking, or network load
balancers, we have
persistent disks.
Those end up being resources.
So you can think of product,
and then resource as a subtype.
And then we have a start
time and end time. ,
And essentially
inside of this table,
we're going to get a new
record for every transaction.
So for every project
and resource type
we are going to get a
new entry in our table.
And that start and end time is
going to be, at most, one day.
So you know that Google
Cloud has per minute billing.
So you could have
an instance that
runs for only a few minutes
and that will get billed.
But if you have it
open for multiple days
you will get multiple
records for each day.
And then inside here
we've got our project.
And inside that we get
our project metadata
like ID, name, and labels
for the project itself.
And then here's also the
labels that we get for all
of the objects inside of GCP.
So this is the labels
that Vic mentioned
where you can label
things like BigQuery
tables or your instances with
your tags to identify things
like production and
development environments
or whatever you see fit.
And those get exposed here
as part of the billing data
as well.
So you can then slice and
dice your data based on that.
And then here we have the
of usual things like cost,
and currency, and
the amount of credit.
So you'll see things in these
credits like sustained use
discounts.
So for VMs the
sustained use discounts
will be exported here in
the billing as a credit
against your billing account.
So that's our table.
Its pretty straightforward.
So if we go ahead here and
just take a look at it.
We've got a table here.
We can say, select our
project ID and then
the sum of our costs maybe.
And then go down here
and group by project ID.
By project ID.
We go ahead and run that,
which is just a simple query.
We can see that we'll
get our billing data
for our couple of projects.
Since I started
exporting billing data
this project has had about
$7,000 billed against it.
And this project has had
about $2000 billed against it.
So you can do those
type of queries.
And you can think
of any type of query
that you want to, anything.
or you can use the
power of BigQuery
to actually, or to slice
and dice your billing data
and gain insights that way.
So you can do these
type of ad hoc queries
against the BigQuery table.
But that's not actually
what's interesting about that.
We want to do more
powerful things.
Your finance officers
and your finance folks
are not going to be writing
SQL probably every day
to figure out the costs
for your resources.
So what they're
going to do is have
something that's much
more visual, something
more like a dashboard.
And so that's what I want
to show you guys today.
So this is actually
the Google Data Studio,
which is a really easy
way to create these kind
of dashboards, right?
And show them to
your finance officers
and to your finance folks
and they can play with them
and get an idea of what
the costs look like.
So let's take a look
at one of those.
And it looks like I didn't
actually create one.
VIC IGLESIAS: Uh-oh.
Ian's going to have to
figure this out on the fly.
IAN LEWIS: Yeah so we're
going to have to do it live.
VIC IGLESIAS: Let's see
if he can do it live.
I have a faith.
What do you guys think?
You think Ian can get
you guys a dashboard?
Live?
IAN LEWIS: So we're
going to do this live.
So this is good because we can
get a sense of how easy it is
to do these kind of dashboards.
so also, we can think of, just
to get us in the mindset here,
let's imagine we have, you were
either a startup or something
and we've got our finance
officer breathing down
our neck, he wants our report
in 20 minutes or something
like this.
So we need to quickly
put together our report.
So the first thing that you do
when you create a new report
inside of Data Studio is you
get a blank page like this.
And then you're prompted
to add a new data source.
So here, we can click
a new data source.
And then in here there's a
bunch of different data sources,
but the one we care
about is BigQuery.
So we'll click that.
And then click our project
name and our data set.
And then we'll get our
BigQuery export table here.
And once we selected
that we can click Connect
and that will add
it to our report.
And what's really cool is that
because BigQuery is a table
and it knows the schema, that
schema comes into our report.
So here we've identified
all the fields
that are available
in that data source.
And these correspond to the
fields in the table, right?
And then each of
those has a type.
And then we can use those to
actually create our reports.
So we don't actually
have to write any SQL.
And we'll see how to create
those reports in a second.
But here we get a little prompt.
We'll add that to our report.
And you can view
the data sources
by clicking on the
Resources section
and do Manage Data Sources.
you can of see all of the ones
that are added to the report.
So there, were only going to
add one actually for this one,
but now that we have a
data source let's go ahead
and create a little
bit of Chrome
just to make this look nice.
Add a header, some
nice GCP blue.
And then we're going to
add an image actually.
Go here, put in an image.
Go to File, go to the Desktop.
Because, you know, I have these
Google Cloud logos just hanging
around my desktop.
VIC IGLESIAS: You got
to make it look flashy.
IAN LEWIS: Yeah, you
got to make this flashy.
We want to wow our
finance officer.
So we did that.
And then we'll add a little
title just to add our text.
And we'll make this really big.
Eight and this in white.
Awesome dashboard.
Right?
This is pretty
easy so far we just
created a little bit of Chrome
just to make it look, nice.
But this is where it gets
interesting we can start adding
these graphs to our report.
So first, let's
just add a pie chart
and see what that looks like.
Whoops.
Click this.
And once I add a pie
chart Data Studio
will figure out the fields
from our data source
and it will, by default,
put in some values.
So right away you get some
pretty interesting reports.
And in this case, it's a
little bit small to see,
but you can actually see that
this pie chart is showing us
our costs by a byproduct here.
So here we see Compute
Engine and App Engine.
So this particular
billing account
we have mostly Compute Engine.
About 78% of our costs
are at Compute Engine
and 20% of our costs
are App Engine.
But I don't want to do
it quite at that level.
I wanted to do it at, a little
bit more granular level.
So what I'm going to do is
change the size a little bit
here.
And then I'm going to
change the fields here,
the dimension that
I'm going to be using
for this particular report.
So instead, I'm going to
choose the resource type.
Now, if we choose
the resource type
we get a much more
granular pie chart.
And this guy is going to tell
us that we are, put over here.
We can see based
on the resources,
so we can see this is our GCP
instances, or GCE instances.
This is our persistent disks.
So persistent disks are
about 16% of our costs.
And then, frontend
instances are 11,
and Data Store is
nine, and so on.
We'll go out here,
back to the Edit mode.
Move that over.
And then, what I'm
going to do next
is I'm going to
add a date filter.
And what these do is allow
you to have a date dropdown,
essentially, in the report.
So this makes the reports
really interactive.
And what you can do is, when
you're viewing the report,
you can actually
select a date range
and that will apply to all
the graphs within the report.
So you can then, not just
create a report for this month,
you can create a report
and then have it .
Be interactive and you
can select the date ranges
that you want to
have for that report
So here we'll select
a default date range.
And this data set just
happens to be from December
to February.
Let's that.
And then we'll add
another filter here.
And this is a filter control
that is shown as a table list.
This is actually a
little bit small to see,
but what this does is
allow you to filter
by a particular
dimension as well.
So here we've got, it created,
by default, the product.
So we can uncheck these
and filter by products.
But what I want to do is
change the dimension here
to be the project ID.
So this particular billing
account has two projects on it.
And we can see
that in our filter.
So if we go back, we go
back here and look at it
we can see that we've
got two projects here.
And then one more.
We're going to
add a time series.
And this time we're
going to make a time
series based on our costs.
So here's our daily costs,
essentially, over time.
And then, but what
I'm going to do here
is I'm going to add a
break down dimension.
And this break down
dimension will actually
break all the costs down over
the particular dimensions.
So here, I want to break
costs down by product.
So I'm going to select
the product field.
When I do that, that's going
to break it down by product.
So you'll see a line
graph on this per product.
We can see that
we're overwhelmingly
using two products.
One of them is GCE,
so the Compute Engine.
And one is App Engine.
You can see the Compute
Engine costs don't really
change over time because we have
the same amount of VMs running.
But App Engine changes
as the load comes in.
You can see that over time.
And that's really helpful.
So just in a few minutes you can
get a really, really neat graph
that's interactive and shows
you a lot of information.
Let's actually make this
a little bit smaller
so we can see the whole thing.
And then, it's
actually interactive
here so what we can
do is we can say,
view the data over the last 30
days or just for the last week.
And you can do that by just
changing the date fields here.
And all of the SQL queries
are generated for you
and then applied to the graphs.
And we can also do that
here for these filters here.
So if we uncheck
one of these, it
will remove that particular
one from our project,
or from our dashboard.
So here, we've unchecked
the My Web App project
and just left the GAE app.
And so, we can see that this
particular project is using
App Engine and its
costs are basically
just frontend instances
and Data Store Read Ops.
And if we go back
the other way, we
can see the other project
is a GCE based project.
So you can see
that that is using
things like GCE instances,
persistent disk,
as well as load balancers.
And here we can see that we've
got network load balancing,
we've got other
custom instance types,
and then we've got other
another set of load balancers.
So the load balancers
are actually
a fair bit of our cost.
So maybe we could think about
ways to reduce that cost later.
So this is a really
neat dashboard.
And you'll notice that
I didn't write any SQL
queries against BigQuery.
it just knew the
fields and it knew
how to use the fields
based on our types
to generate the queries for
me and generate the graphs.
I didn't have to do any of that.
And that's great
if we want to do
something that's
relatively simple,
but it's still powerful.
But if we want to get
really into our data
we can actually do things
like custom queries.
So here I'll hit
the Edit mode again.
And Data Studio allows you
to create multiple pages
for your reports.
So here I'm going
to add a new page.
And in this new page I'm
going to add a few new graphs.
But these graphs are going
to be slightly different.
What I'm going to do is I'm
going to create a bar graph,
but I'm going to
populate this bar
graph with data from a
custom query that I write.
And so, we'll see what
that looks like here.
So when I go here I can
say, choose the data source
for this particular graph.
And what I'm going to
do is actually just
create a new data source.
And when I do that,
I can click BigQuery.
And instead of clicking
on My Projects,
I can go down here
to Custom Query.
And then, from there you choose
a project for the Custom Query
to run in.
And then, you can just
type your query in here.
And I've got a query that
I've got written already.
VIC IGLESIAS: Pretty simple
query as you can see.
IAN LEWIS: This is
run-of-the-mill.
VIC IGLESIAS: Not
too complicated,
anybody can figure
that stuff out.
IAN LEWIS: Yeah, it's
a pretty nice one.
Well, if we have some time we
can actually go through this.
VIC IGLESIAS: Well,
the interesting thing
is, what Ian's going to
do here is basically try
to predict the
future with BigQuery.
IAN LEWIS: Exactly.
VIC IGLESIAS: So you
can tell your CFO
what you think you're going to
spend later without even having
to use the pricing calculator.
IAN LEWIS: Yeah.
VIC IGLESIAS: Let's
see what kind of magic
he can come up with.
IAN LEWIS: Yeah.
So what this is actually doing
is it's, over the last three
months of data,
it's actually doing
a linear regression over the
last three months of data.
And then we're going to
solve that linear regression
for the next couple of months.
And what that's going
to do is predict
the current month and the
next month's billing data.
So we'll see what
that looks like here.
VIC IGLESIAS: How many lines
of code was that in the query?
IAN LEWIS: In this query?
This one is 83 lines of code.
VIC IGLESIAS: That's not bad.
That's not bad.
IAN LEWIS: What we
get out of this is,
we get these three fields
from the SQL query.
And those fields get
translated into the fields that
come into my report, right?
So Data Studio knows,
from the Custom Query,
what the output fields are.
And then we can use those output
fields to generate our report.
So here we have.
A future balance and a
balance field and I've
separated those two.
But basically, the
past months will
have data in the balance field.
And the future months will have
the data in the future months
field.
And I'll show you
why I did that,
but it has to do with
the report itself.
And then I'm just
going to add that
to my report as a data source.
And then in here,
in the dimension,
I can select from the data
that came back from my Custom
Queries So here I'm going to
select Month as my dimension.
And as my metric I'm going
to select Balance here.
And so, you can see
that I've created
a bar graph for the past
three months of billing data.
So these are my costs for
the last three months.
And so, I'll go back.
And what you can do is you can
actually add multiple metrics
to a lot of these graphs.
So what I'm going to do
here is add another metric.
And this time I'm going
to add the future balance.
So normally what you
would do in these cases
is multiple metrics
would show up
as bar graphs that sit
next to each other,
but because these are mutually
exclusive for each month they
show up with big
spaces in the middle.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to do a little bit
of a hack with this.
I'm going to change
it to multiple colors.
And then I'm going
actually stack these.
And since they stack
on basically nothing,
they kind of look like
they're next to each other.
So this is a little
bit of a display hack,
but you can see that
I did that so that I
can put the past months in blue
and the future months in red
here.
And so this is actually
the current month
and the next month.
So I don't actually have
billing data for this,
but I'm actually extrapolating
from my past data, what
my future data might look like.
So you can see that my
past data is trending down.
So we've extrapolated out that
the billing data will go down
a little bit over the
next couple of months.
That's great.
We can predict the future
a little bit and maybe ease
our financial officers minds'
a little bit about how much
we're spending.
But the last graph
that I want to do here
is what really illustrates
the power of using BigQuery,
exporting your billing
data to BigQuery,
because BigQuery can be,
you can put any type of data
into BigQuery table.
And likely you already have
a lot of business data there.
Which we can do is actually
combine our billing data
with data that we know
about our application
in order to create much better
and more richer metrics.
So here what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to create another data
source using a Custom Query.
And I'm going to use a slightly
less complicated query.
VIC IGLESIAS: It's
only 82 lines of code.
I know.
IAN LEWIS: It's actually only
17 lines of code, this one.
But this one is actually
a really simple query.
And I'll go ahead
and connect that in.
But what I'm going to do
is, since my application
is a, that's interesting.
In with the wrong fields there.
I didn't quite copy
and paste it properly.
There we go.
So what I'm doing
here is my application
is a web application, right?
So I'm using Google Analytics.
And I have Google
Analytics Premium
so I'm actually exporting that
data, the analytics data too
BigQuery.
So in this case, I'm just
using my Analytics data.
I'm going to go
ahead and apply this.
To join that Analytics table
with my BigQuery table.
And then generate, essentially,
a cost per unique user.
And so, what I'm doing
here is I get out
a couple of fields, the date
and the cost per unique user.
So I'll add that to the report.
And I'll show you
the graph first,
but then we can look at
what the query is doing.
And I'll explain a little bit
about what the query is doing.
VIC IGLESIAS: One
thing to note is,
despite all of our data sources
here coming from BigQuery,
there are a bunch
of other sources
you can use like
just a regular sheet.
If you've got a sheet
with a bunch of data
that you need to merge
in with some BigQuery,
you can do that as well.
Not everything has to
be coming from BigQuery.
IAN LEWIS: Yeah, right.
So for a single
report you can only
choose one single data source.
For inside a report, you
can have multiple graphs
and each one can come from
different data sources.
But for a single graph,
you need to have,
you can only associate
one data source.
So generally, if you want to
combine multiple data sources
into a single graph, then
the best way to do that
is with multiple tables
and then joining them
with a Custom Query.
And that's exactly
what I did here.
So we'll take a look at what
this particular query is doing.
What we're doing here exactly is
we're taking our billing data,
and this is my billing
table, and then
we're doing a joint on that to
our Google Analytics sessions
table.
And when we do that,
we can extract out
the distinct visitor IDs.
So this essentially gives
us a unique user everyday.
Yeah.
And we're grouping that by date.
And then, we join
that with the tables.
And then, up at
the top here we're
dividing the cost by the
number of unique users
to get the costs
per unique user.
So we can how that
goes over time.
And we can see that we
have some spiky days where
our cost per unique user
goes up really high.
So we can investigate why
that might be and maybe
find out why our
application is becoming
inefficient on those days.
We can also combine
things with, just
like Google Analytics
but data that
happens to be coming
from your application.
Maybe you have log data
that's already created
that you can join it to.
Or maybe you have
some other type
of data about how
many users you have
or the lifetime revenue that
you get from those users.
And you of compare
that to how much
you're spending for your
resources in the Cloud.
So this is very, very
powerful to actually get
a much more holistic
view about how
you're spending your resources.
Not just, I'm spending x
number of dollars here,
x number of dollars here,
but actually per user
how much you're costing.
So that in the future say, if
you have an application that
has 5,000 users
right now, but what
happens if you have 10,000
users or 100,000 users?
In those cases,
you can extrapolate
how much your application would
cost as your application scales
into the future.
And this is also
really good because say
if you are using
multiple Clouds,
who happens to be using multiple
Clouds, GCP plus Amazon?
So a lot of you, right?
So one of those things that
you could do with this is say,
you get your billing
data, you export it
to billing, your
GCP billing data,
you export that to BigQuery, you
get your CSV dump from Amazon,
you put that into BigQuery
because BigQuery is awesome.
And then, you put
those two together
and you can of look at your cost
per user say, for each Cloud.
So say, GCP versus
another Cloud.
What's the cost per user for
each of those clouds, right?
And you can see as your
application scales up and gets
more users, where you're
actually syncing those costs
and where the cost
is more efficient.
So I know that you guys don't
want to pay us more money,
but the way to be happy, for
everyone to be happy maybe,
is for everyone
to realize perhaps
which Clouds have the
best cost per user
and move those workloads
hopefully to GCP.
VIC IGLESIAS: So what we've
shown you today is basically
how to look at your
bill and pay us
less money, which is
totally great for us
we want that to happen.
I think all this power
and these specific queries
are not important as much
as the conceptual pieces
that we've shown you, the
fact that you can bring
different data
sources in the fact
that you can chop up your
bill in different ways,
and especially that you can
use Data Studio to make really
easy dashboards
that you can present
a holistic view of your bill.
And depending on what
questions you're being asked,
you can answer those really
easily with Data Studio.
So that's about it
for our presentation.
[MUSIC PLAYING]